for some time Efron's veganism helped
him achieve his lean build but
eventually he realized that the
restrictive diet was not great for his
health when talking with Men's Health he
said I started intermittent fasting just
after I stopped being vegan my body
wasn't processing the vegetables in the
right way so I decided to stop it and
try something new Efron then went on to
explain that the switch to focusing on
protein heavy foods made him feel
significantly less exhausted after
intense workouts but a part of him also
wished that was not the case the actor
admitted moral of course I still wish I
was vegan